hello everyone this next game is like an
amazing piece of art it's absolutely
timeless if you ever decide to hang a
chess game on your living room wall and
this is the game to choose it's quite
remarkable the game was played in 1923
in Denmark Copenhagen it was the time
when Aaron himsa which moved to
Copenhagen and the tournament featured
six players are names of its oddly
tartakov free Samish rule of Spielman
and two Danish players Jakob sin and
Muller and earnings which won this
tournament it was a very nice victory he
wanted with eight out of ten points I
think it was six wins and four draws and
this is the game British Danish versus
aron nimzowitsch and this game does hold
the title the immortal tubes one game
and you'll see why so a semi she's white
and the names of each is black let's see
this game we have d4 Knight to f6 c4
Knight to f3 sorry II 690 to f3
we have b6 g3 Bishop to b7 Bishop to g2
Bishop to e7 Knight to c3 with castles
castles and the name 'search plays d5 so
we have the Queen's Indian defense we
have Knight to e5 and now c6 by our
names which of course overprotecting
that d5 pawn we have seek after sandy 5c
captors and e5 and Bishop to f4 and the
names which plays a 6
he plays a 6 with an idea of b5 and
creating a strong outpost here on this C
4 square and the idea is to bring the
knight maybe which Knight d7 to maybe B
6 and then to c4 or maybe Knight to c6
to a5 to c4 depending on what white
white place so assembly goes rook to c1
and we have b5
names of each continues with his plan
and Queen to b3 so we have a knight to
c6 and here well sandwich plays and
Knight captures and c6 but names of each
himself says that this is actually a bad
move as the
this night here at c6 nimza which calls
him a ghost as well the threat of Knight
a5 to c4 isn't really that great and
which really should have considered
before capturing here because white
already spent two movies with Knight f3
and 95 and now this is a strong knight
on e5 and now playing Knight captures on
c6 that's three moves and well you've
basically threaded traded your strong
night for four names oh it's well still
still undeveloped night but okay Sims
played at night captors and c6 we have
Bishop captures in c6 and h3 we have
Queen to d7 King to h2 and the Knights
to h5 and again here names oh it says
that instead of this night to h5 move he
could have played something like Queen
to b7 and then get this night from f6 to
d7 to be six to eight five and sorry and
to c4 again but he decided that playing
on the Kings side would be better here
so he played nine to h5 we have Bishop
to b2 of course not allowing Knight
captures on f4 and names which plays f5
we have Queen to d1 and now before by
names o H and it's well this night
doesn't really have a good square to go
to so he has to go to b1 and do we have
Bishop to b5 now attacking this e to
pawn because the White was actually
threatening efore here and this would
would have been a good move because well
this pawn could not be captured since
the Queen would be attacking this night
on h5 so first names which plays Bishop
to b5 not allowing the pawn to move so
Samish moves that rope to g1 and now
he's threatening efore but here is nimza
which is great idea he plays Bishop to
d6 and he actually allows this efore
move so symmetry of course plays that he
plays efore now of course this is very
nice for white as he managed to push
efore so black can't really capture
because his Knight is hanging but
actually this was named so it's idea
he plays F captures on e4 and he invites
savage to capture the night mh5 so well
what's white gonna do he captures that
night Queen captures on h5 and he plays
rook captures on f2 and this isn't
really that bad of a position I mean he
gets to put two points for that night
and I mean look at this night here on b1
it's not like he's getting into the game
anytime soon so it's it's practically
like news oh it isn't down a piece okay
same it goes between two G 5 and we have
rook a to f8 now doubling up at this F F
file King to H 1 and we have rook a to
f5 with an attack on the Queen and we
have a queen to e3 and here another very
suffocating move by named Zoe she plays
it Bishop to d3 and well this is a well
this is cramping White's position even
more but even more than that there is a
threat of a rook to e2 not trapping the
Queen and of course this has to be
defended same place Roxy to e1 now
protecting the e2 square and this is
where names of each plays his immortal
move this is the greatest move of all
it's it's it's move so good that well
all the other moves pale in comparison
you're you're welcome to try and find it
it's nothing fancy or you know nothing
spectacular but do try and find it I
will give it a couple of seconds if you
want to pause the video and discover the
move okay those of you who found it
you're you're you're quite acquired and
amazing players and news which in this
position played 86 and it's in this
position that Friedrich Samish resigned
the game as this is the position this is
the mortals oops wrong position and any
move white makes here loses the game
instantly well not instantly but even
even stockfish couldn't get out of this
one but okay let's let's cover some
options here well let's let's run let's
try and find a move for white obviously
this Knight isn't going anywhere so a
three is impossible series impossible
so maybe if you would like to jump to d2
but bishop the c1 is unfortunately
impossible because if Bishop c1 then
simply Bishop captures an b1 this loses
a piece and okay let's try some other
moves if for example a three trying to
play just a slow move then simply a5 and
what we're back to where we started
nothing really happened here let's let's
try a move like g4g for attacking the
rook it seems like a good idea but it
runs into rook f2 f3
Erick 5 2 F 3 and this unfortunately
traps the Queen as the Queen has nowhere
to go so this is the whole point of this
h6 move the g5 square is now covered and
if instead of g4 white would try
something like king 2 H 2 then again
rook rook 5 2 F 3 and this again well
traps the White Queen so any any other
move by by white well if there is any
other move for example white could play
something like B 3 and and B 3 but black
would simply just hand white one more
move I'm more like rook to f7 can be
played and now it's again White's move
and again White is whatever move so
pretty much the same thing but like I
said in this position
Sammy thought that this was enough
suffering and he resigned the game and I
would like you to have to check out the
quote on top of the board as I found
this quote on chess Gamescom it's quote
by by a user named phony-baloney and
it's actually a combination of two
quotes the one is the most powerful
weapon in chess is to have the next move
by David Bronstein it's his famous quote
and below that is the reply by Friedrich
Samish like yeah right semi-sheer does
have the next move but whatever whatever
move he makes loses the game so yeah
this is the game this is the immortal
so this one I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon